how bad has the explosion been
so there was uh thank you very much
thanks for having me um
i'm hearing goma yes there was an
explosion on saturday
the 22nd and that uh caused destruction
of about 3 000 homes
and left about half a million people
without access to portable water
and caused the movement of panic in the
population i mean this is because
this volcano has erupted before in 2002
and before that in 1977
with devastating consequences for goma
this time
thankfully it stopped just at the
outskirts of the city
and the destruction of that volcanic
explosion was was limited
but the volcano excuse me
has continued in activity and as a
result of that
on thursday the governor ordered the
evacuation of half of the city of goma
for
fear of a new explosion nevertheless
i mean not it seems as bad as what
happened in 2002 but
still quite devastating it was it was
devastating it could have been much
worse
uh but now we're still again the
volcanic
event has not been declared over by the
scientists
and this is why over 400 000
people had to leave the city of goma as
you see in your images many of them by
foot in various directions some of them
crossed into rwanda about fifty thousand
others went uh uh south towards the city
of bukavu
and minova and sake uh and others went
north through the territory of rusuru so
all in all about 400
000 people with him have left the city
of goma
with their bare belongings and need now
humanitarian assistance to be able to
sustain themselves
where they are i mean i would like to
recall our viewers that
the drc is a very very poor country
uh people here 77 percent of people live
under the poverty poverty line and it
remains one of the world's major
humanitarian crises
we the humanitarian community attempt to
provide assistance to 10 million people
every year to save lives but it's a tall
order i'm guessing to do that
at this moment people who are displaced
i mean they need
access to food they need access to clean
water i mean we fear that there could be
an uh uh um some of the zones are
endemic with cholera so we want to avoid
an epidemic
they are need shelter material and they
need
uh to sustain themselves in a situation
which we hope
will not be very long-lived if indeed
the scientists can call this event off
and people can return to goma because
the niaragongo will have been quiet but
for the time being
we're not there we're still in a moment
of zone of danger
uh i hear in this my house in coma i can
feel
earthquakes tremors and we
hope the volcano will not explode again
but of course we cannot be sure
thank you so what is it like living
through this currently a week after
the explosion with these quakes
well i mean um we have taken measures
uh with the united nations and the ngos
and their humanitarian workers uh
to comply with the measure by the
governor to evacuate part of the
to relocate people outside of the city
so we have evacuated all of our
non-essential staff for the dependents
the families of many of them were local
staff
congolese and we have kept only a group
of
what called essential workers here in
the city of gomer to plan
the humanitarian assistance now is the
moment in which the congolese need us
we have made an appeal to the world
for humanitarian assistance in the drc
this appeal is badly underfunded
we will be needing more resources also
to be able to respond to this new
emergency
so i appeal to uh thank you very much
for your interest in the situation and
appeal to
all your viewers to feel solidarity with
the people of the drc that need our
support now more than ever
yeah so really an international appeal
for help do you think that assistance
will
be forthcoming even though it perhaps
may take some time
well i mean last year our appeal was
funded at only 40 percent
uh this is a very uh uh uh
you know it's very inadequate it means
that we're barely able to
to meet the standards of assistance that
we would like to
to meet for a population of 10 million
so we need
more resources in order to be able to
provide
emergency life assistance to millions of
people
for this specific situation now around
goma
the united nations has already the
emergency relief coordinator
has contributed 1.2 million dollars
the european union has announced a
contribution of 2 million
2 million euros but more resources are
needed for this specific situation
but this is within the framework of a
much broader appeal
for which we ask for the world's
generosity